how are you mark I'm pretty good Conan
yeah you know what I really respect the
fact that when you had two frogs peeing
on you yeah you didn't go for the cheap
laughs you immediately oh my god no I
went with the honest route which was I'm
covered in urine I'm very unhappy I
think that was way to go yeah how are
you how's everything going very well
thank you thank you no I'm good you got
a good New Year's everything went good
for you well you know I don't know you
know New Year's is weird to me I mean
you know what amazes me about New York
is that the thousands of people flocked
to this city but I'm not saying we're a
stupid culture all right but hundreds of
thousands of people flock to Manhattan
to watch a ball lower I mean what is
that is that that what hundreds of
thousands of people go who look shiny
[Applause]
actually also a secret hypnotic effect
going on some sort of subtext you can't
see on television just as the ball hits
it says he this is why you hear people
saying happy new year
but the subtext is dispersed throughout
the city and vomit on the locals
dispersed throughout the city I heard it
actually I picked it up yeah so so
you're not you're not big into this
thing well here's your idea here's what
I did in New Year's we went to a small
Italian restaurant and there was nobody
else there and we actually had New
Year's with the kitchen staff behind a
little black-and-white TV set just
sitting in front of it going whoo you
know and I hugged The busboy and and as
you were walking out this was the
perfect New York moment some guy they'd
locked the front door so we had to go
out the back door and he walks us
through the door and me and my
girlfriend say well Happy New Year and
he goes Yeah right
[Laughter]
think about it yeah that's pretty big
was Asian I think it was better than
most news I remember when I was in high
school it seemed to me that when I was
in high school every New Year's Eve I
was in a car with four other guys
splitting a pint of Southern Comfort
right it like at third like 30 seconds
before midnight we'd always be going oh
we're not gonna make it to the party
every New Year's Eve we have to be all
right happy new year giving that
southern and then of course you know
half hour later someone would be
vomiting to a journey song and back of
the car you know
I think I spent most of my high school
my entire youth image in the back of my
friend's Firebird with my head in
between two gents and try Axl's just
gonna throw up like journey blaring
don't stop how sad for you name College
at least I moved up to at least I was in
a bar you know this is college here you
guys count down okay okay from five and
say Happy New Year okay but this year
must have been different right you
weren't hungover well no you know but it
was funny because I went out into the
city and it's it's really funny to see
people today after New Year's like you
know like it's gonna be a great new year
and you see these pale people standing
out in front of coffee shops just do dry
heaving you walking around the city you
notice yeah because there's coffee shops
like might for some reason my corner you
wake up here's what I don't know if this
happens all over the country but one
morning you wake up in Manhattan and
there's a Starbucks across the street
all right yeah and then two days later
you wake up and there's one caddy corner
- all right but no one says hey what's
going on here why you know I don't
understand no people don't say that they
just go oh now I don't have to cross the
street you know to get coffee and I'm
starting to realize what's going on here
is that all right there's a little bit
of a conspiracy theory I'm not much of
one here's what's happening is that
these gourmet coffee shops it's not that
they make the coffee any better they
just make it four times as strong so you
don't want it you need it do you
understand they're drug dealers that's
what I'm telling you yeah they're drug
dealers with gift baskets don't trust it
I've already got the slogan for
Starbucks ought to be Starbucks coffee
the first times always free
then they get your I see yeah because
they do get you up then you don't
realize it and then you know now I know
the drug okay I'm explaining okay once
they get you hooked they humiliate you
just like any other drug dealer you know
what I mean cuz they know they got you
but it's sort of subtle with Starbucks
see cuz I drink my coffee black I
understand what it is it's a drug just
give them my body so I can start my day
the understand because if you have
enough coffee in the morning you even
like your job for a couple hours let's
see there should be a line for regular
users who understand their addiction and
people who don't quite know what they
want or just they're dabbling do you
understand because here's how how they
humiliate inevitable you go into
Starbucks you gotta wait on line
together like four or five people who
don't quite know what they want so I got
to sit there why someone goes that way
is it cappuccino does that it's like oh
shut up don't hide your problem with
steamed milk just get on with it get in
the body I don't know why I'm not angry
about it it's just you know you don't
want people getting in you in between
you and your drugs you know because then
once you get up to the counter this is
how they humiliate you on top of not
being able to get to the counter you
walk up there and you're like hi how are
you yeah can I get a small could I get a
small coffee and they're like oh do you
mean you want a short it's like look you
made me like this don't make me speak
the language how about they're kind of
contemptuous people sometimes sometimes
Starbucks is is it's not as bad they
seem to have they they have the
enthusiasm of born-agains for some
reason it's Starbuck mm-hmm I don't
quite know why but some of the more you
know the independent coffee shops
there's a little bit of an attitude
involved now I don't know when it became
sort of common fair for people who work
at coffee shops to be condescending the
other set let me see let me explain this
if I see one more 35 year old loser okay
steaming milk okay and trying to
convince me with his presence they're
steaming milk that he's on some sort of
higher aesthetic and cultural endeavor
I'm gonna vomit on his cute green apron
you understand
yeah because wait wait for me vomit way
of expressing yourself but if you can do
that you should buy the skill - god
bless you if you can just go you know I
don't like you're wrong not everybody
can do this that's hard it's years to
get back and on this we I can't but I
have a guy that goes with me sometimes
do it to him
alright but for me okay who is it for me
there's something that undermines
intellectual credibility when a guy's
standing there and he's going oh yeah I
saw that film I could have done a better
job directing that you want cinnamon on
that yes four things you show me a
little cinnamon Oh
Walmart thank you very much for coming
in spreading the hate with us
[Applause]